[Music]
after Joe Schumacher made Batman silly
never leave the cave without it but
before Zach Snyder made him a joke my
god Chris Nolan made a movie that got
the Dark Knight just right Batman Begins
see one of the best yet oddly not that
successful Batman films that was so good
it allowed Christopher Nolan to do
whatever he wanted afterwards except
distance himself from the franchise in
this perfectly told superhero origin
story back when we weren't sick of
superhero origin stories that
realistically explains how a boy became
a crime-fighting bat ninja instead of a
trust-fund kid with a deep-seated fear
of wells I mean had to be even odds he'd
become well man right experience of
feature-length attempt to ground Batman
in reality where the Batmobile was just
a bridge-building rocket car Wayne tech
had laying around the Batcave was simply
part of New York's Underground Railroad
father was involved in the Underground
Railroad and the bad shoes that someone
a giant cloud of angry bats are total BS
but who cares how cool is this
follow a law on every step of Bruce
Wayne's heroic journey from cosplaying
as a hobo to stealing food to blowing up
a school and witnesses brutal training
at the hands of the Liam of Neeson's I
mean the League of Shadows a group with
a sinister plan to stop crime by using a
microwave gun to vaporize their special
fear Jews to kick-off the purge
wait what I thought this was supposed to
be the realistic one that sounds like
something Adam West would go up against
but the League of Shadows aren't the
only criminals plaguing Gotham
there's also Batman who if you think
about it is a violent criminal answers
to no one waging a one-man war on the
law itself
[Music]
sorry still counts as murder if you make
a train do it joining this loner on his
one-man quest for justice are a lot of
other people like Alfred a butler so
loyal he'll drag Batman sedated
girlfriend into the back of a car no
questions asked little device
Lucius Fox a man who might be helping
Bruce to be a better serial killer for
all he knows you can't tell me exactly
what you're doing when I'm asked I don't
have to lie Jim Gordon a cop with the
morals glasses and mustache of Ned
Flanders Rachel Dawes my childhood
friend with a mysterious past of
drinking condensed milk
Alfred still keeps the condensed milk on
the top shelf and boy is that King
Joffrey that is him are you giving a
military hardware take him out before
it's too late so strap in with a movie
that saved Batman from ponds and
irrelevance
with the right mix of gritty realism and
comic-book theatricality that's a
perfectly focused character driven story
except for the whole third act they get
their machine into a station it'll cause
a chain reaction little paper eyes the
entire city's water supply and the fact
that half the dialogue is cutesy
repetitions of things someone said
earlier it's a bit technical but gee if
you thing is is that my company's future
secure
one defines me didn't you get the memo
shut up
no wonder this would be so good I only
had to write half a script
starring Tara leave Gotham Abby draws
actually Rachel Dawson's Creek serious
blue if I only played Bruce Wayne can
want to not be wasted in this movie but
he is and what does the Fox say a
ring-a-ding-ding orangutan be help us
Wayne got his groove back the League of
Shadows has been a check against human
corruption for the thousands of years we
sacked Rome loaded trade ships with
plague rats burned London to the ground
canceled Firefly made crash win Best
Picture discovered Justin Bieber made
Harambee a meme it's time to embarrass
the Dark Knight worse than Joel
Schumacher did Batman you're a cunning
strategist and a master of theatricality
but I found your one hidden weakness
getting this beaten out of you
the screen junkies Roast of Batman watch
now holy scorched earth if you'd like to
watch the roast of Batman click the Box
in the left to see the caped crusaders
greatest foes get a rise out of the Dark
Knight who always pays their taxes not
Batman the wick has wikked the last of
the wicked witches and wolves what is
happening in the happening
that's number way stray he says stir a
whole shuttle shed